vou começar falando sobre a minha
experiência a partir da minha
experiência pessoal relatando uma
narrativa sobre a rede cultura viva em
campinas
como ela se relaciona com a rede
nacional e falar também sobre quais são
os impactos sociais políticos e
econômicos que estão relacionados com os
pontos de cultura e com a rede e cultura
viva começar contando do início é o
início da história a partir da casa de
cultura tainã
não sei se vocês conhecem é ficar ali na
vila manoel padre manoel da nobrega nec
também conhecida como vila bela e é hoje
a casa de cultura tainã tem 25 anos ela
foi fundada em 1989 e na época é que ela
foi fundada médio para ela ter
sobrevivido todo esse tempo é porque ela
trabalhou com um trabalho comunitário e
principalmente porque ela visava o
empoderamento e autonomia daquela
comunidade que participava dali foram
dizer diversos projetos néon um deles
que é bem famoso nos sons é o tambores
de aço que é uma banda é um conjunto
formado por tambores que são é tão boris
feitos de tambores já são aqueles de de
óleo né que passam por uma por uma
mudança artesanal e eles emitem sons
então tem inclusive a escala é cada
ponto que você toca tem emite um som
diferente e tudo mais
e eles trabalham com muito relacionados
com a rede dos quilombos no brasil né
ele está é participam de uma rede que a
rede mocambos é uma rede muito pouco
tente ela procura articular as é todos
os quilombos pelo pelo campo do brasil
eles estão tem um diálogo com o
ministério da comunicação e conseguiram
instalar por meio desse diálogo foi
feito um projeto tudo mais né com com
dinheiro com recurso conseguir instalar
telecentros em diversos pontos em
diversos quilombos do brasil a rede
mocambos trabalho inclusive com o
georreferenciamento que é próprio
independente do google então se algum
dia algum motivo google internet sofrer
algum tipo de alteração não for mais
livre como é hoje
eles já têm essa independência e eles
trabalham também nessa questão
relacionada empoderamento autonomia né
sempre relacionado com comunicação água
e terra que são os três elementos
fundamentais para você ter independência
e autonomia hoje em dia é o vou falar
rapidamente sobre o conceito dos pontos
de cultura né os pontos de cultura são
referência numa rede horizontal de
articulação horizontal porque todos os
pontos são são vistos a partir de uma
mesma posição é que é a idéia da rede é
eles trabalham com recepção e
disseminação de iniciativas culturais e
tem uma parceria que a relação entre o
estado ea sociedade dentro dessa rede
agrega agentes culturais que articula
impulsiona um conjunto de acções suas
comunidades e dessas entre sintam cada
ponto desenvolve seu próprio trabalho
mas esse ponto também se relaciona com
outros pontos desenvolvendo trabalhos em
conjunto e existe uma programação que de
quatro em quatro anos e se chama teia
que até o conceito de rede mesmo né
pensando no lançamento de fios que
gerando uma teia que a oportunidade dos
pontos espalhados pelo brasil se
encontrarem e trocarem conhecimento
trocarem experiências trocar em cuba
pura e juntos trabalharem por
articulação pelos seus próprios direitos
culturais né
é um ponto de cultura não tem um modelo
único existem diversos formatos não
existe uma existe foco existem alguns
que trabalham com cultura popular
alguns que trabalham com assuntos
ligados à identidade assuntos ligados à
saúde
teatro enfim não existe um formato é o
que existe é o tipo de atuação e o tipo
de trabalho que se faz que se visa um
trabalho comunitário né
o cultura viva começou na gestão do
gilberto gil como como ministro da
cultura
ele foi criado por uma foi inspirado
nesses modelos ac de campinas
principalmente na casa de cultura tainã
e foi a partir daí que houve a
inspiração pra esse trabalho para se
colocar essas a esses atributos para os
pontos de cultura do trabalho em rede
trabalho comunitário empoderamento e
autonomia
o ponto de cultura invenções de sonhos
também faz parte dessa rede era um ponto
de joaquim egídio que trabalha com um
teatro de bonecos que também é uma
cultura tradicional brasileira já foi
reconhecido também como o patrimônio
imaterial então juntos esses pontos com
mais outros que fazem parte tanto daqui
da rede de campinas como outros pontos
de cidades próximas né
é esses pontos conseguem se unir e
trabalhar através da das mídias através
das tecnologias de informação e
comunicação por uma articulação em rede
que já trouxe vários resultados que são
resultados relacionados com direitos
culturais com política com cidadania
políticas públicas voltadas para pra
todo o povo brasileiro que vai ser usado
de acordo vai ser operacionalizado de
acordo com os critérios de cada política
né
então existe um sistema nacional de
cultura o sistema nacional de cultura é
um sistema que está a implementação no
brasil e coloca o brasil como vanguarda
no mundo de um país que está em primeiro
tanto o sistema nacional desde então
isso vem vindo já ao longo dos últimos
15 10 15 anos né
o sistema estadual de cultura que também
vem sendo implementado sistema municipal
que igualmente está sendo implementado
porque é importante falar disso é
importante falar disso porque são
direitos são recursos né
é importante entender que a cultura ela
é também um espaço de cidadania e é um
espaço de economia é cada dia mais
quando a gente vê é a falência de vários
modelos econômicos e sociais que a gente
vê por aí
ela tava falando aqui sobre moda
sustentável né de como é é cada vez mais
distante da realidade trabalhar com
modelos que que não são acessíveis né
como é que toda essa rede tem se
articulado e as pessoas acreditem nelas
trabalham com cultura elas não trabalham
em outras no em outros empregos ou não
existe um modelo que está sendo criado
está sendo desenvolvido a partir desses
conceitos que estão sendo implementados
pelos pontos de cultura
a iac em campinas é pela pela reunião
desses grupos nós é que fizemos uma
dentro de uma conferência municipal de
cultura um debate sobre o conselho
municipal de políticas culturais
então foi um processo bem democrático né
que chegou à conclusão final de dois
dias de debates no formato de um
conselho municipal
agora isso tá passando para a câmara dos
vereadores e vai ser votado
a política nacional cultura viva outro
resultado concreto né que estabelece e
agora é lei é porque ele sabe quando era
programa de governo
em troca o governo corre o risco de o
programa deixar de existir quando algo
se torna lei isto é uma política pública
democratiza dá para ser operacionalizado
em todo país implementada
aqui em campinas também nós já
conseguimos a aprovação da lei cultura
viva municipal foi nessa semana que
passou é foi o motivo de comemoração
porque resultado de uma rede de pessoas
trabalhando conjuntamente
em prol de um objetivo que é um objetivo
comum como a todos
a lei do património material de campinas
também campinas é uma cidade de
vanguarda que reconhece o patrimônio
material para entre 1 e material é
aquilo que não é tangível né
a gente conhece o patrimônio como por
exemplo um prédio antigo que é tombado é
aqui a gente fala sobre o património
material como por exemplo a capoeira é
um patrimônio material o jogo que é o
que é a mensagem para vocês também é
conhecido com o patrimônio material de
campinas
o edital mais cultura educação nas
escolas é um também o resultado de
articulação em rede por uma política
pública com a presença desses pontos não
é conseguindo conquistar mais direitos e
uma forma de distribuir melhor os
recursos é e qualquer ponte é disso tudo
bom
é como eu a minha experiência vem a
partir desses pontos nem e hoje estou à
frente desse espaço que estas am cultura
que é o espaço cultural um centro
cultural na região central de campinas
como é que tudo isso acaba influenciando
né a gestão e esse espaço que é um
espaço da diversidade da cultura de
campinas inicialmente a estação é
conhecida como espaço de grandes eventos
onde shows feiras e bazares acontecem
dentro dos grandes eventos
tem a questão da legislação das normas
do alvará do corpo de bombeiros etc
mas os grandes eventos são pontuais
então como é que a gente faz para ocupar
aquele espaço que é lindo que a cidade
tem muito carinho mas no dia a dia
durante a semana como é que se ocupa
aquele lugar que a gente não consegue
fazer um evento grande todos os dias né
então a gente faz isso trabalhando com
processos culturais aí dentro do
processo de gestão foi criado um
laboratório de produção cultural com
seis frentes de trabalho
qualquer atividade que aconteceu dentro
da estação estaria numa dessas e 26
frente de trabalho ou em maio de uma né
a gestão compartilhada produção
colaborativa comunicação colaborativa
formação memória e relações
interinstitucionais
a partir daí é nós começamos a trabalhar
com a política do sim o que é a política
do sim política do sim é pode fazer é um
show sim pode fazer um teatro sim o
ensaio de teatro sim sair de dança sim
sim sim sempre coordenando uma coisa com
a outra nekoto procurando colocar falar
sempre o número máximo de atividades
simultâneas respeitando alguns limites
por exemplo show de rock não dá pra
acontecer junto com o espetáculo de
teatro porque a questão do som acaba
afetando demais e o teatro precisa desse
leis né mas essa é uma das poucas
restrições
aí dentro disso dentro da gestão
compartilhada é nós fizemos um processo
de gestão compartilhada com alguns
agentes da sociedade civil alguns grupos
e coletivos que estavam próximos e que
propuseram um plano de trabalho e
começamos a trabalhar com gestão
compartilhada de alguns espaços entre
eles têm a sala de toninho que é uma
sala de teatro para mais ou menos 80
lugares onde nós trabalhamos com uma
temporada que é uma vez por mês
são três dias de teatro não é mais do
que isso porque a sala é totalmente
operacionalizado por integrantes da
reduzir a geradora que essa sociedade
civil
ao mesmo tempo que essa sala fica no
barracão onde funciona também um projeto
de hip hop então música alta e teatro
não dá pra acontecer simultaneamente
então a gente tem que ir maneja a sala
da salvaguarda da capoeira de campinas
que também trabalha com gestão
compartilhada com um coletivo formado
por 15 grupos de capoeira de campinas
então mais uma vez é dando e dando essa
oportunidade sendo capoeira patrimônio
imaterial em campinas reconhecido né
dando esse reconhecimento e
proporcionando pra eles também esse
espaço para debater é um espaço que vem
rendido muito
resultados para essa rede da capoeira é
existem articuladores é que são
internacionais que trabalham com a
capoeira como eu vou representar o
brasil fora fora do país né em outros em
outros países dentro dessa rede né
e muitas vezes isso acaba não tendo
visibilidade aqui a casa do hip hop que
também é agente faz gestão compartilhada
com a família clipse que é um outro
espaço que é muito pujante é diariamente
aos sábados a estação é totalmente é
dominada pelos jovens que dançam o vagão
do teatro de bonecos é o antigo vagão é
o único vagão no brasil que tem um
teatro de bonecos funcionando inspirado
numa no modelo de mar del plata
o ateliê da estação que também nós
começamos por meio de oficinas né e hoje
em dia ele já está totalmente empoderado
como era um espaço um túnel dentro da
plataforma que ligava um lado ao outro
da plataforma um espaço totalmente
inativo que agora tá vivo colorido cheio
de exposição cheia de atividade
a cooperativa paulista de teatro que
também tem uma sala que funciona lá e
desenvolve uma série de atividades e
conecta a artistas de todo o interior do
estado de são paulo
a fec que é a associação de modelismo
ferroviário de campinas é também tem uma
maquete de 3 que é aberta ao público aos
sábados que também é um coletivo formado
por algumas pessoas que são apaixonadas
por três e trabalham com a maquete e
aqui umas algumas imagens aqui no último
dia das crianças que foi um dia a gente
fez uma ação conjunta coletiva e
colaborativa né
nesse dia parte houve uma iniciativa que
foi por parte dos coletivos dos grupos
pra fazer a uma programação do dia das
crianças nesse dia toda parte de
apresentação foi toda trabalhada com
economia colaborativa cada grupo
investiu seu tempo e seu trabalho pra
proporcionar um dia das crianças que nós
conseguimos convidará quatro
unidades que chegaram nós conseguimos os
ônibus conseguimos nos alimentos
conseguimos material para fazer pintura
no rosto
foi tudo isso foi trabalhado com a
economia colaborativa
então pra concluir tudo isso que eu
falei de forma bem rápida né
são conceitos que são relativamente
novos bem vindo aí de uns dez anos né
sendo trabalhados que é o poder amento
protagonismo social desses grupos dessas
comunidades desses coletivos articulação
trabalho em rede que hoje também já foi
falado é muito importante que quando a
gente consegue os melhores resultados
cada um dá um pouco do seu trabalho um
pouco do seu tempo o resultado é
magnífico a economia colaborativa que
que tem a ver com isso também cada um dá
um pouco do seu tempo arranjos
produtivos que quando a gente consegue
ter um novo modelo econômico também pra
manter o dinheiro em circulação de uma
forma mais próximo é a gestão
compartilhada acreditando que uma
responsabilidade do poder público
mais uma responsabilidade também é da
sociedade civil e é assim que a gente dá
o protagonismo e empoderamento ea moeda
complementar que eu não citei aqui mas
tudo isso pode ser é e é uma tendência é
cada vez mais dentro dessa economia
colaborativa entender que nem todas as
relações estação por dinheiro elas podem
passar por outras unidades que podem
existir outros nomes né mas aí a gente
teria um tema para outro debate é então
é isso que finaliza falando de cultura
viva cultura vida né pra gente entender
que a cultura é uma dimensão muito
importante da cidadania e dos direitos